today we're gonna talk about Disney Plus
this was actually a really wildly
requested video so many of you guys have
been tweeting me leaving me comments
asking me what are my thoughts on Disney
Plus am I going to subscribe what shows
am i watching and what do I think
and obviously I'm a huge Disney fan it's
something that so many of us grew up
with and just the nostalgia factor of
Disney Plus alone is amazing a huge
thank you to Disney for sponsoring this
video
when I first logged into Disney Plus it
was just like this wave of emotions and
I saw so many shows that I had watched
when I was younger for example one of
the shows that I recently watched that
was from my childhood I remember so
distinctly watching this old version of
shaggy dog with my family and it was
weird watching it because I had the same
feelings that I had when I was younger
so it's kind of bringing back all of
these memories and it's so cool that
Disney has such an expansive library and
it's not just Disney that you're getting
access to Pixar Marvel Star Wars
National Geographic and so much more
it's sort of overwhelming but in the
best possible way Disney Plus is $6.99
or if you want to just buy the whole
year it's $69.99 I'm gonna put a link in
the description where you guys can get a
7 day free trial check it out and I just
want to know what you guys think because
I have been having the best time I've
been so busy over the past few weeks and
I've been traveling a lot which is great
because I love watching content on
flights because that's usually my time
to just kind of hang out and if I don't
have any videos to edit I'm looking for
content to watch and what's great is you
can still have this stuff offline so you
can download the shows and take them on
the go most planes do have Wi-Fi but you
definitely don't want to rely on Wi-Fi
to watch any content ever just be sure
to download it before you go and I'm
sure many of you guys are probably
traveling for the holidays and if you're
not I'm sure there's gonna be some
holiday downtime so this could not be a
more perfect time to watch a lot of
content another thing that is really
great is it's available on so many
different platforms when I was traveling
back from Nashville I knew that I had
about like a four and a half-ish flight
and this was the day the Disney Plus had
launched so in that flight before we
took off I watched the first episode of
the mandalorian I watched encore I
watched a lady in the [ __ ] it was
really cool to see
obviously I have a dog and I love my dog
more than anything so to see these dogs
interact with each other and having real
genuine conversations and feelings I
mean I have conversations with my dog
all the time but to see that in like an
updated version of lady in the [ __ ] it
was pretty great I also watched the
Imagineering story Walt set a standard
early on what he imagined is such a fun
show that covers a bunch of amazing
moments in Disney history you get to
meet a lot of incredible people who
helped bring so many creative ideas to
life there's just so many great shows
another show that I was so surprised by
was encore I'm not really like the
biggest fan of Broadway or like plays I
enjoy them but it's not something that I
go out of my way to watch so when
preparing for my review I watched the
first episode and it made me almost cry
the premise of the show is a bunch of
adults who kind of go back to recreate
their high school plays the first one
was Annie and they did such a great job
storytelling because a lot of these
people obviously aren't professional
actors so they were able to pull so many
great stories out of these people
Kristen Bell is one of the executive
producers of the show so obviously I had
to give it a shot because I'm such a
huge fan of hers as well the second
episode is the beauty in the Beast
episode which was also really good they
have all kinds of Disney movies I mean
they even have The Simpsons
scrolling through to see some of my
other favorites they also have some cute
little pixar shorts there is one where
it's four key from Toy Story 4 which is
probably I think now one of my favorite
movies of all time everything about toy
store was incredible the story the
characters it's just so good oh my gosh
xenon girl with 21st century if I was
able to be a Disney star at one point I
think this probably would have been me
the description is 2049 and teen xenon
happily lives on an orbiting space
station when her curiosity gets her in
trouble as we send earth for punishment
it needs to learn how to fit in this is
amazing because I feel like I'm related
so much to the show Hannah Montana Boy
Meets World that's always I think for
how much easier paying and what you're
getting this is such an amazing deal
especially for families and the fact
that you can just download it and take
it on the go is really great so much
Turner and hooch I kind of was going
back to all of the shows that I watched
when I was younger 1989 I just realized
that I didn't get a chance to really
talk about the mandalorian yet I cannot
believe how incredible this show is I
mean obviously it's Star Wars and I love
Star Wars I love the entire world of
Star Wars that this show there is
something so special about it I wish
that I was filming my reaction because
when it got towards the end of the first
episode I just believe my eyes and what
I was seeing and the best thing is I
avoided all spoilers I didn't read any
reviews I wanted to go into this knowing
nothing I didn't even watch any of the
trailers I avoided absolutely everything
so this experience for me was so great I
look forward to hearing what your
reaction was to it and I cannot wait to
see what happens and the rest of these
episodes the character that I'm
referencing that you don't know what I'm
talking about it unless you do know what
I'm talking about has made me cry every
single episode this character is
extremely cute that is all I'm gonna say
because I don't want to give anything
away but all jeez it's amazing it's so
great this is kind of my first
impressions I guess it's not really
first impression since I've watched
hours and hours of content at this point
and this could not be a more perfect
streaming platform for people who are
fans of Disney and Pixar and Star Wars
and Marvel it has everything that we
love Disney Plus is offering people a 7
day free trial so I put a link in the
description if you want to check it out
I'm gonna go watch the latest
you
[Music]